[Music]
for nearly half a century advances in
medicine and biotechnology
have been hampered by one very tough
unsolvable problem
how do proteins fold up but now thanks
to
amazing advances using ai this grand
challenge is considered
solved opening the path to an entirely
new era
of ai assisted computational biology
and so therefore in this video i want to
cover one of the most
anticipated machine learning models of
the past years
which has finally been released in all
its glory
i'm talking about deepmind's latest
version of the alpha fold
protein folding model so for those of
you who are not very familiar
let's listen to david baker one of the
gurus in the protein world
explaining what proteins really are
proteins some of which you see inside a
cell here
carry out essentially all the important
functions in our bodies
proteins digest your food contract your
muscles
fire your neurons and power your immune
system
everything that happens in biology
almost happens because of proteins
that's right proteins are everywhere
now if you don't yet have a good
intuition about how these fascinating
molecular machines work and how they're
created
from the genetic material in your dna i
really really recommend you watch my
previous video
on molecular biology first because you
know we're going to be
building heavily on those concepts over
here and
this video will just make a lot more
sense if you have the necessary mental
framework
to place all of these ideas all right so
in this video i'll start by quickly
introducing the historical events
that led to the five decades long quest
to solve the protein folding problem
we'll then briefly revisit the original
alpha fold one architecture
before diving into what's arguably one
of the most
impactful machine learning models of
this decade
alpha fall 2. we'll explore its full
network architecture and training
principles
and after that we'll zoom out a little
bit and look at what this breakthrough
means for the fields of computational
biology
and protein design so are you ready to
dive in deep
my name is xander and welcome to archive
insights
[Music]
so what is the protein folding problem
well in his acceptance speech for the
1972 nobel prize in chemistry
christian anfinsen famously postulated
that in theory
a protein's amino acid sequence should
fully determine its structure
this hypothesis then sparked a
five-decade quest
to computationally predict the protein's
3d structure
based on its amino acid sequence a major
challenge however is that
the number of ways that a protein could
theoretically fold
is just astronomical i mean in 1969
cyrus leventhal noted that it would take
longer than the age of the universe
to enumerate all possible configurations
of a typical protein
by brute force calculation yet in nature
proteins fold spontaneously
some within milliseconds a dichotomy
often referred to as
leventhal's paradox this paradox then
led to the assumption
that instead of trying out different
combinations at random
well nature must be using predictable
folding pathways
to arrive at the native state of a
protein so reliably and rapidly
and ever since then scientists from all
over the world have been trying
to model these folding pathways using
advanced computer simulations
that try to approximate the physical
interactions
underpinning the folding process now the
hard truth however is that after
decades of incredible work on
physics-based modeling tools like
rosetta for example
in many cases the accuracy with which
they can predict the 3d structure
of a folded protein is simply not good
enough to be practically useful
enter deep learning now over the past
few years in ai we've witnessed a surge
of learnable programs
that excel at challenging problems that
are too complicated for us humans
to write down an explicit solution for
now the main idea here is that
these systems learn a differentiable
program purely from example data
a good analogy here is what happened a
few years ago
in chess and go were traditional engines
like stockfish
that were manually engineered by decades
of handcrafted rules
were surpassed by end-to-end trainable
deep learning architectures
like alphago and alpha zero now the
training data for alpha fold comes
mainly from what's called the worldwide
protein data bank
that stores a freely accessible archive
of all known protein structures
each of which is the result of a very
expensive measurement
using things like x-ray crystallography
and
almost a phd worth of work to analyze
all the data and determine the final
structure
so in other words determining the
structure of a protein has traditionally
been
very challenging and very expensive
which is exactly
the problem that alpha fold addresses
now before diving into the latest
deepmind paper i quickly want to
highlight the original alpha fold one
architecture which won
the casp 13 competition at the close of
2018
because a lot of the ideas from that
earlier work
have been refurbished in the new
architecture after that we'll look at
the updated version of alpha fold that
won the casp 14 competition
in 2020 with incredible results so alpha
fold one
is actually a fairly straightforward
architecture
the entire pipeline starts with an
intricate feature extraction process
whereby external databases are used
to find similar protein sequences to the
query sequence
to form what's called a multiple
sequence alignment
so all right what is a multiple sequence
alignment
well from studying different organisms
over the course of evolution
we know that the three-dimensional
structure of a protein
is much more stable over time than the
genetic sequence
that encodes that particular protein so
in other words
mutations to the specific amino acids
that form a protein are
quite common in nature but changes in
structure are much more rare
and if you think about it this actually
makes a lot of sense
the reason is that most living organisms
descended from common ancestors
so the proteins performing all these
biological functions in their bodies
well they will have very similar shapes
because they need to keep carrying out
the same functions like
you know transporting oxygen or breaking
down sugar molecules
so if a mutation were to occur in the
dna
that drastically affects the shape of a
folded protein
well then that protein would most likely
stop working properly
and there's a good chance that the
organism would simply die off by natural
selection
and so the only mutations that survive
are the ones that don't really affect a
protein structure
if you then compare the sequences of a
particular protein over multiple species
that descended from a common ancestor
well you end up with various sequences
that you know should have strong
structural similarities
and this is exactly why multiple
sequence alignments carry such relevant
information
for the protein structure prediction
task and yes
i mean i know that it's tempting to try
and solve the protein folding problem
using just the single sequence
information of the target i mean
this is what happens in nature but the
reality is that we just
have like a ton of sequence data sitting
in these databases
which provides valuable information
about protein structure
so why not use it all right so the first
version of alpha fold
took the target amino acid sequence and
it then starts crawling all these
databases to find
evolutionary matches in related species
of the animal kingdom
this msa information is then combined
with
some additional input features processed
and reshaped
into a two-dimensional array and fed
into a deep residual
convolutional network that's very
similar to what we use for things like
image classification
and the main target output of this
resnet is the distrogram
of the actual protein that we're trying
to predict
all right so what is a distagram well
a distagram is very simply a 2d array of
distances between
every pair of residues in the protein so
at row i and column j
you will find the distance between amino
acid i and amino acid j
in the 3d shape of the folded protein so
essentially a distrogram is a
two-dimensional projection
of the 3d shape of a protein and
since the distance from i to j is the
same as from j to i
the real distrogram well that will
always be a symmetrical
matrix around the main diagonal now why
would you use a distrogram instead of
directly predicting the 3d coordinates
you might ask you know why take this
intermediate step
well there's actually a lot of reasons
someone might want to do this but one
simple and important one is that the
distagram
is invariant to rotations and
translations of the protein
so if you take the 3d structure and you
move it around and rotate it
well the relative distances between the
amino acids stay the same
and so the distrogram is the same so
this makes your target much
easier to learn since you don't have to
figure out some
canonical way of aligning the protein
every time you do a structure prediction
and now rather than trying to directly
predict the target distrogram
alpha fold actually predicts a
distribution over distances
so for every pixel in this 2d matrix
alpha fold will predict
a distribution over 64 possible distance
bins
which is incredibly useful because it
provides an
estimate of how certain the model is
about the distance between two
particular residues
and then finally to get from this
predicted distrogram distribution to the
final 3d shape
alpha fold 1 used a gradient descent
approach
essentially a physical model of the
protein chain is constructed
which is parameterized by the phi and
psi angles
between every two consecutive residues
and
this backbone geometry is then
iteratively refined
using a scoring function that combines
the predictions of the neural net
with a set of physical simulated forces
to figure out the most likely protein
conformation
according to the model now i know that i
skipped over a lot of details here but
that's the essence of alpha fold one
you first collect a multiple sequence
alignment you then predict the
distrogram using a resnet
and then you optimize the protein
backbone using the predicted distrogram
in combination
with a set of physical forces so now
let's transition to the updated version
alpha fold 2.
and now while deepmind's alpha fold has
definitely been at the forefront of
protein structure prediction for the
past few years
i can't make this video without at least
mentioning some of the other amazing
effort in this space some examples and i
can't mention everyone include
the amazing open source work by the
baker lab at the university of
washington
in seattle and more recently some
incredible efforts to replicate the
advances of alpha fold
by the open source community and while
deepmind refrained from publishing their
paper for
almost a year after first announcing
alphavote ii
it's very likely that they were feeling
the building pressure of these ongoing
efforts breathing down their necks
and almost forcing their hand into
publishing their amazing work
before getting scooped by the broader
community because a lot of these ideas
were also being explored by other groups
so this is another
great example of how a lively open
source community
is a really good safeguard against
building monopolies
all right so now that we've set the
stage it's time to dive into the machine
learning architecture
of alpha fall 2. hold on to your hats
because it's about to get a little
technical
so alpha fall 2 consists of three
essential building blocks
the first part of the architecture is
the pre-processing stage
where the input sequence is used to
query additional information from
external databases
this information is then mapped into an
msa and a pair representation
which are refined by what's called the
evo
former a 48-layer deep transformer-like
network
that uses attention mechanisms to update
the msa
and pair representations the outputs of
the evo former
are then processed by the third
component of alpha fold
called the structure module which
basically transforms
the abstract representations formed by
the evil former
into concrete three-dimensional
coordinates
of the protein geometry and with that
overview in mind
let's take a look at each of these
components separately
so given an input chain of amino acids
alpha fold
first creates a multiple sequence
alignment just like in the first version
by searching for similar evolutionary
sequences in a genetic database
additionally though alpha fall 2 will
also search for
structural templates which are known
protein structures
that have similar sequence parts as the
query sequence
now during training these structural
templates are sampled in such a way that
the model
sometimes receives very bad templates or
no templates at all
which has the effect that the network
cannot just rely on copying
a good input template to get an output
structure but it really is
forced to learn from the sequence
information instead
alpha fold then integrates all this
information from the input sequence the
multiple sequence alignment and the
template structures
into a pair representation and an msa
representation
which will be used for further
refinement
in fact because there is so much
external data available
this pre-processing pipeline is usually
repeated a few times
leading to different versions of the
pair and msa representations
which can then be averaged together
before flowing
into the structure module so once the
msa and pair representations are formed
they are forwarded to the
evo former the evil former is a 48-layer
deep network
that contains two separate flows of
information one for the msa
representation on top and another flow
of information
for the pair representation at the
bottom all these 48
blocks have individual parameters so
this is not a recurrent network unlike
the structure module that we'll discuss
in a bit
each block has an msa and a pair
representation as
input as well as its output and it
processes them with several layers
now the layers inside the evil former
well they actually have a lot of
very clever technical tricks that make
it particularly
suitable for updating the protein
representations coming from the input
stage
and the main idea here is to allow the
network to iteratively refine the
information
from the msa and pair representations by
allowing the two modalities to exchange
information
which essentially enables direct
reasoning
about the spatial and the evolutionary
relationships
in the protein so to translate this in
plain english the idea
is that the multiple sequence alignment
contains information about the
evolutionary trajectory
of mutations for the particular protein
in question
but in order to extract all the relevant
information from this msa
well you would have to know something
about the structure that you're dealing
with
and this is what the pair representation
tries to do so in essence these two
flows of information
are just interacting together to solve
an evolutionary puzzle
about the input protein now i'm not
going to go into all the technical
details of how exactly the evil former
does this since there's just
way too much stuff and you really need
to read the supplementary to the paper
if you want to dive deep in the rabbit
hole
but very briefly the msa stack uses an
attention schema called
actual attention whereby alternating
layers
apply row and column attention
sequentially
the idea being that the row wise
attention
allows the model to reason about
information
from each of the aligned sequence
separately while the column attention
lets the model reason about
relationships between the aligned
residues
in different sequences of the msa stack
additionally the row attention is
influenced by a branch coming from the
bottom
allowing the information from the pair
representations to flow
into the msa stack likewise another
branch of the network goes back down to
the bottom flow
to enable an update of the pair
representations
now interestingly this operation is
applied within
every one of the 48 blocks in the evil
former
enabling continuous communication
between the evolving
msa and pair representations now the
pair representations themselves
are updated using another very specific
mechanism
that essentially tries to make the 2d
representations
consistent with the three-dimensional
structure that they represent
and to understand what's happening here
consider that the purpose of these 2d
representations
is to encode things like inter-residue
distances
but there's a bit of a problem here
remember that the feature vector at
position i
j should encode the distance between
residues i
and j so now imagine creating a triangle
in 3d space
going from i to j the k now because
these
two-dimensional features are the output
of the neural net
well it's very likely that the predicted
distances in the 2d feature map
are actually incompatible with any
possible physical triangle
in 3d space and this is why this part of
the network
allows the 2d feature map to update
itself
in such a way that it becomes more
consistent
with an actual three-dimensional
structure again
if you want to learn how exactly alpha
fold does this you should definitely
check out the paper because there's some
very clever tricks
here but so that's the general idea
behind the evil former to gradually
mix information between the msa and the
pair representations
to prepare for structure generation in
the structure module
so the final piece of alpha fold is the
structure module
now this module transforms the abstract
representations that come from the evil
former stack
into a concrete three-dimensional
protein geometry
it does this by passing the first row of
the final msa representation from the
evil former
through eight network layers that all
share the same weights so this is
essentially a recurrent network
that iteratively refines the spatial
geometry of the protein
evoformer's pair representation is also
used in this process
now the structure module operates on a
concrete
three-dimensional backbone which is
represented
as a set of independent rotations and
translations
for each residue with respect to a
global frame of reference
so this is actually pretty fascinating
because it completely ignores the
fundamental constraints
that we know to be present in nature and
yet it appears to work
really really well now in the first
iteration of the structure module
the 3d coordinates are not yet known and
so everything is initialized
to an identity transform which the
authors
fittingly call the black hole
initialization it simply means
that at the start of the structure
module all the residues in the protein
are located at the exact same point
which is the origin of the global frame
and they also have
the exact same orientation now after
this initial
black hole initialization the residue
gas
is then updated iteratively in two
stages
first a novel geometry aware attention
operation called
invariant point attention or ipa
is used to update the sequence
representation without changing the 3d
positions
then an equivariant update is performed
on the residue gas using this updated
sequence representation
now again the invariant point attention
mechanism involves a whole bunch of very
clever tricks
that were specifically designed for the
purpose of protein structure refinement
in a nutshell the invariant point of
tension augments information
coming from the local frame of each
residue such that the activations
are invariant to rotations and
translations in the global frame
so this idea is very related to all the
recent efforts around spatial equivalent
transformers and graph neural networks
if you want to learn more about this i'd
highly recommend
this blog post from fabian about
equivariance
in machine learning it's an amazing read
another interesting note is that
the proposed frame rotations are
represented using something called
quaternions
rather than the usual three by three
rotation matrices
that we're all used to now i suspect
there's a bunch of different reasons for
this
but quaternions actually do provide some
interesting benefits over
regular rotation matrices for example
they can be represented using just
four numbers instead of the nine numbers
that you need
for a three by three rotation matrix
additionally interpolation between
various angles is a perfectly
smooth process where you don't have any
special edge cases like
you have for angles where you know 0
degrees and 360 degrees
is essentially the same angle but it's a
different numerical value
so this could make quaternion
parametrization
much easier to optimize with gradient
descent and finally alpha fold also
fixes the first of the four quaternion
numbers to be
one and what this does is that it biases
the learned rotations
towards very small values which is
really desirable if you have an
iterative updating scheme if you want to
learn more about quaternions
three blue one brown has some amazing
videos on the topic
they're highly recommended so without
going into too much detail here
the main idea is that by iteratively
updating the sequence representation
and the backbone transformations the
black hole initialization of the protein
is gradually adjusted until the final
backbone geometry emerges
and then finally a shallow resnet is
added on top of the final abstract
representations for each residue
to predict the torsion angles for all
the atoms in the side chain
which ultimately leads to the 3d
coordinates
for every atom in the protein structure
and voila that's it
that's the full network architecture of
alpha fold
2. now let's take a look at how this
beast was
actually trained so alpha fold was
trained using a combination of
four different loss components the most
important of which
is what's called the frame aligned point
error or
vape loss now what fape does is it
essentially compares the
atom coordinates for the predicted
structure with the ground truth
structure
but it does this many times over using
a different alignment for every local
residue frame
and this has the effect of putting extra
importance on getting
locally consistent structure for every
residue
rather than only focusing on the global
coordinate accuracy
the idea here is that it's very very
hard to get all the atom coordinates
perfectly right and more often than not
you want the model to focus on correct
substructures first
and only then start worrying about
global placements
now aside from this fape loss there are
a number of auxiliary losses
first the final pair representation is
linearly projected
to a distance distribution scored with a
cross entropy loss
so here the evo former stack is being
supervised by the target distrogram
second random masking is applied to the
input msas and the network is
tasked to reconstruct those mass regions
using the output msa representations
with
a loss very similar to a model like bert
so here the tricks from unsupervised
language pre-training have been applied
to the input msa stack
which essentially forces alpha fold to
learn
about the evolutionary relationships
between the sequences
in the msa third the single
representations at the output of the
structure module
are used to predict per residue lddt
scores what this means
is that alpha fold tries to predict how
well it thinks it's modeling the
position of every residue
and this is a very useful output because
it shows you
where alpha fold is very certain about
its predictions
and where it isn't and finally there are
two
minor auxiliary losses that are used to
better predict
the side chain positions and avoid
structure violations
whereby two atoms would be at the same
place for example
and now the main purpose of all these
different losses is to attach an
individual objective to each major
component of the model
which serves as a guide during training
for the purpose of each subunit
now because the backbone is modeled as a
residue gas there's always a possibility
the network could predict
atom coordinates that clash meaning that
two residues are predicted closer
together than is physically possible
so in order to resolve any remaining
structural violations and clashes
the final predictions are relaxed with a
restrained energy minimization
using the amber force field now towards
the end of the paper there's a very
interesting graph
showing how different elements of the
alpha fold algorithm
affect the final performance of the
model and on this ablation study
you can see a few final tricks that i
haven't mentioned yet
for example alpha sold used something
called self-destination to increase the
size of its training data
essentially alpha fold was first trained
on all
available protein structures in pdb but
then
it predicted the structures of roughly
300 000
additional proteins with unknown
structure
these predicted structures were then
added to the training data but
only the residues that alpha fold
thought it predicted with high precision
were used to perform gradient updates
another trick used
is called recycling whereby outputs of
the model
are recursively fed back into the same
modules
essentially increasing the depth of the
model and giving it more iterations
to refine the predicted protein
structure so
as you can see alpha fold is not the
result
of a single breakthrough idea that
magically solves the protein folding
problem
instead it's a collection of cleverly
designed
and novel ideas that have been improved
over many design cycles
resulting in this amazingly well
engineered system
and there you go that's alpha fall 2 in
all its glory
so to end this video let's briefly zoom
out a little bit and talk about the
bigger picture
i mean is protein folding really solved
now
well yes and no first of all
let me state this very clearly alpha
fold is a tremendous engineering
achievement by some of the most talented
ai researchers in the world
the model is able to predict the
structures of most
single domain proteins in biology with
incredible accuracy
and it's undeniable that this will
herald a completely new era in
computational biology
where ai will be used as an
indispensable tool
for designing new drugs understanding
disease pathways
fighting viruses and much more at the
same time however alpha folds accuracy
isn't always perfect for example many
processes in biology rely on
large protein complexes whereby many
different proteins come together
to form complex molecular machines which
are currently
outside of alpha volt's capabilities
there's also the notion of
generalization i mean
alpha fold was trained on a data set of
proteins that naturally occur in biology
but we don't really know how good its
predictions will generalize
to completely new de novo proteins that
we might want to design with these new
tools
additionally most proteins function by
changing
shape with respect to targets they bind
to and
these molecular dynamics well they're
not captured by
alpha fold's static view of protein
structure
being able to model the flexibility of a
real protein in these different
conformations
will be crucial to study protein protein
interactions
that being said though it's very likely
that the ideas proposed by the alpha
fall team
can be extended to those new challenges
given the right types of training data
and engineering efforts
all in all i think many people will
agree with me when i say that this is
probably
one of the most impactful machine
learning models of this decade
so the fact that deepmind has finally
published their paper and released their
code
including pre-trained model weights is
an incredible gesture towards the
scientific community
in fact we're now living in a world
where you can simply
run alphafall the world's most advanced
protein folding model
directly in your browser using google
colab with zero setup
giving you state of the art structure
predictions for
any protein you're interested in i mean
honestly
that's pretty mind-blowing and with that
i would like to thank you very much for
watching till the end of this video
please consider supporting this channel
on patreon making these videos
is a lot of work check out my pen site
page if you need one-on-one meetings to
discuss your own projects
but most of all say thanks to the
billions of active proteins keeping you
alive right now have an amazing day
[Music]